When we started talking about the Emily Dickinson
Archive, we wanted fans of Dickinson's poetry
to really see the original manuscripts. There's
something about the handwriting, and the energy,
that I think conveys to people some of that
passion that she felt. The Emily Dickinson
Archive will be truly Open Access: no fees
are paid for access to this material. Unlike
most authors, she did not publish in her own
lifetime. And so, for Dickinson in particular,
to be able to see the manuscripts as she wrote
them is very important. So we're very excited
about developing new tools to take advantage
of new digital technologies. In addition to
just having the image of the manuscript, we
have transcriptions that various editors have
worked on. And so you'll be able to see how
her poetry was presented to her public over
time. You'll be able to look up a word that
she used, and the context in which she used
it, and then look at how that word was defined
in her dictionary. A scholar will be able
to look at all of the variations; make their
own transcription; put notes next to it; and
then save that all in their own workspace.
So there's a nice interrelationship between
all of these tools within EDA. What I hope
will come out of the Emily Dickinson Archive
is something that's really a new model for
how we approach making manuscripts and scholarship
available in an Open Access website.